people people in there like where is
everybody where is where
here okay I can't I can't make things go
faster all right I was H you know I I'll
say it I was having to make a thumbnail
for for King all right so so it takes
time to do these things who's late added
for dirt no one was late everyone was on
time it's it's I had to make king of
thumbnail uh he's got a he's got a nice
little where's this where's the stop
snitching sign at where it got to we got
to have a stop snit we don't have a stop
snitch yeah I'm I'm get one made for
your show we don't have a stop snitching
sign I call a call a police on this
fraud hold on so so what we're gonna be
doing is at the end of the show King
will be preparing his his next new video
next new I don't know why I said next
new but his next new video definitely
stay tuned for that it's a it's a it's
it's a nice little video man and I took
a little extra time for that thumbnail
guys took a little extra time for that
thumbnail I hope you guys appreciate so
what's going on you guys Lord addict
here with dark gy and uh King David
welcome back to the addict show we've
talking about the past present future
game I got my co with me DK GRE what's
going on DK what up hey man they call it
the Oreo show man show some damn respect
man don't
yck y dumb world don't you start
man
Paul y hold up no or in order for me an
Oreo show King would have to go first I
would have to go second D would have to
go third there we go there now it's the
Oreo show it's the Oreo
show yo we gonna do that
today y that was funny though that that
that one was that was unique at least
you guys ain't copying people man at
least you guys crazy got a $2 sub from
the angry therapist who's late addict or
dirt like I said no one was was like and
then we got our guest with us man uh you
know I ain't doing the whole thing King
uh Cog does uh we got wow Lord King Xbox
front line and that's my my fault it's
what you named yourself so that's what
you're being referred as what's going on
King I'm I'm doing a little good I guess
I I don't I don't get an intro I'm like
like come on man you open the see hey
hey D this ain't no 4H hour long show we
got time concern restraints okay this is
true I I've seen I've seen how Dirt move
if I well here's the thing like I've
always I've always structured the show
it's it's like a rotating door we
getting in and out in and out in and out
like like a Denny's like a Denny's yeah
like a denes like Denny's so we we got a
pretty uh hectic show for you guys today
man we got the Call of Duty reviews you
know we didn't talk about it last week
and I'm curious to hear D's opinion on
it we got Spiderman 2 got a patch but
apparently didn't fix nothing because
there's nothing wrong
wrong we going to talk about that we got
Xbox visiting blizzard uh apparently
they they're promising to uh in some way
shape or form giving them back their
independence uh you know first off what
you guys been playing dirt I'm kind of
curious what you've been playing I've
been playing Allan way too my man and I
gotta admit it start off real slow I'm
like okay you know cuz I love the first
one I was like I know it's a it's
survival horror but it's a little slow
then it started to pick up for me a
little bit so yeah I'm loving it right
now I believe I'm at the end um I
believe I'm at the end so yeah I've been
playing that exclusively you know
besides my little sports games because I
wanted to finish it you know then I
wanted to go back and finish
Starfield got Assassin's Creed Mirage
got RoboCop you know I got some more
games I wanted to play so did you did
you um finish Starfield the first the
first part of the camp the first
campaign yet or no not yet uh no I don't
believe so no okay cool I got like 70
hours in it but I didn't yeah you you
like me yeah walk around take time
squirrel stuff yeah yeah yeah I ain't
going livee man I I attacked that game
front and center I hit it from every
anle pause
man and I walked out and never never and
never texted the person
again rushed a minute out man I had to
get through that Starfield I still love
it I think it's an amazing thing we are
going to talk about you know it has been
confirmed that Monday is the nominations
for game of the year so I'm curious to
hear on your guys's opinion on that uh
next Wednesday gonna be lit because it's
either gonna we're gonna go we gonna
celebrate or we going in there ain't no
in between it's gonna be one or the
other one or the
other going
in what you been playing man what you
been playing well what I'm playing right
now is uh the extended
family oh my God extended family yeah
Xbox extended family you get a 10year
deal so this is what I'm playing I'm
playing Mario Wonder right now and if
y'all wondering if it's good I can tell
you hell yeah and N I've been playing
Ellen wake too
um
fortnite oh my God me and add got a
chance to play yesterday this is the
first time the first game yeah yeah we
won we we went out there and put funny
we got on top uh we was on I can't
remember the lake is called and we got
on top of that house in the middle and
it's just like there was so much
distance between them and us and they
had to go through cuz there's not a lot
of ways to to to move around in water
and like there back then season one and
they got they stay true to the most part
to keeping how it was back then and oh
I'm sure they were annoyed because
they're up at the top they shooting down
and and they can't get to us because all
we have to do is back up a little bit
they got to jump and get it through and
I just we we must have
killed to kill 10 people in three
minutes like no we had we had 35 kills
uh total as a team uh it was me up
confusion and yeah we was playing squads
and as a team we had 35 kills and and it
was just uh three of us when we we beat
squads we we beat four we beat teams of
four which is S three what's what's up
people what's up yeah I mean if you got
your best bring them up I want your best
in brightest pause um but yeah I'm
playing I was playing that
and I was trying to get back to uh
Assassin's Creed and oh I'm playing
thirsty
suas yo you thirsty dudes out there if
you thirsty and and this is youro you
really need to try it as a game pass
it's called thirsty suas is uh from Anna
parara uh the people that brought you
that one game I did not like that game
that they brought out but this game I
actually like this game right here so
hey is like that the one with two chicks
on the cover yeah yeah and one and one
chick doing the situps
yeah yeah okay it is so dope it's a dope
game it's if you like Dayton Sims this
is a Dayton Sim with a Twist so check it
out and I'm gonna give my review on some
a couple other games that I'm playing
but that's a little bit later yeah so
you know like I said we got a stack show
for you guys think we're gonna talk
about the little stuff uh first going
into this you know let's start out with
the video game of the uh Video Game
Reward dominations uh it's interesting
that Jeff Keeley tweeted when they were
being revealed he's never done that in
my in my uh you know knowledge I think
he have I think he have before yeah he
let you know what day he is gonna be I
don't remember him ever maybe it's
because this year it's so like people
want to know I didn't notice when he did
it the past years but like so it's it's
Monday I think like the 13th I don't
know what day is Monday Tumi I don't
care but so it's Monday and you know
there's a stack list of games like the
amount of games that's coming out this
year is just absurd and we have you know
probably one of the best Years of Gaming
uh upon us and I I'm just curious you
know we'll start with King like you know
what what is your first off do you think
Starfield gonna make it and second off
do uh if you if if Starfield doesn't
make it what do you think will go in its
place I'm curious on those two things
death and destruction
like I'mma keep it I'mma keep it a buck
with
you I already seen the agendas a long
time ago and um I know they're cognizant
of it y'all not saving Kong bro so this
fight is gonna be fight and if if it's a
fair fight like like unano y saw angano
win the fight but he didn't get to win
right I don't care man just make sure
that that that game is mentioned in in
uh Game of the Year Starfield is it
should be mentioned in Game of the Year
um I didn't play Hogwarts cacy so I
can't say anything about that I did play
Zelda tars of the Kingdom I don't think
that it should be nominated but I know
it will be I I can understand why it's
nominated but I do think there are
better structured games this year than
tears of the Kingdom but I understand
why people would vote tears the king I
just personally feel like it was
literally just more breath of the Wild
but just there's there's islands in the
sky now well it's bre it's breath of the
wild with nuts and bolts tacked on to it
so to a point I'd agree that and I think
nuts and bolts did it better
but I'm I'm just saying and y'all gonna
be like yo that's that Xbox bias so what
I'm from Xbox Frontline so what there
you go it is what it is but uh it it's
so many games this year when I started
looking back at it and and I do love I
do love Spider-Man I do love Spider-Man
do I want revenge for the year that God
War won in
2018 hell yeah I want revenge so if
Starfield is nominated and Spider-Man
win I could live with that because that
means I got my revenge like you know I I
I did it I'm I'm down for that um but if
if Spider-Man don't get nominated
Starfield don't get nominated you better
throw his show in the
bushes it is what it is but I want I
want fa to get nominated if it doesn't
get nominated what's in its place don't
don't don't put two Nintendo games in
there don't give me Mario mushrooms and
give me uh tears of the Kingdom don't do
that don't do that um it's either either
or and I think Mario mushrooms is is
really fun right now I'm having a good
time with it um tears of the Kingdom I
don't think it should be but I
understand why it would be so it's
either or pick and Nintendo Nintendo
game one or two it's funny right how we
going to tell them to pick a Nintendo
game we can only pick one Xbox game
because it's only Starfield right and we
can only pick one PlayStation game well
no high five Rush will probably get best
indie game of the year because it wasn't
a a triple A Bank I don't it's it's a
good
start that is not Game of the Year
material to
me and it's it's a good start not saying
that it didn't have great music not
saying that it didn't have great
gameplay not saying that it didn't have
great art Direction it didn't have all
that stuff but that's like that year
stray was that was Strays was nominated
yeah was that last year I think that was
last yeah exactly yeah St stray should
have been there exactly it should not
have been there so I don't I gotta keep
the same energy yeah and you if you look
at like these years that people sit
there I'm so sick and tired and maybe
you guys can agree with me when it comes
to this but it feels like all of a
sudden now everyone is so obsessed with
Metacritic like this is the biggest year
I've seen people obsessed with
Metacritic because it's like if they
can't justify Starfield not being there
by itself so they have to use Metacritic
to like hit it down a couple nachos see
see your stars you know that that was a
Higher One you know uh you know Allen
wake that scored better like they name
all these games are Metacritic they're
like all these games did better and it's
just like okay I can death straining was
nominated for Game of the Year control
was nominated for Game of the Year there
is points yeah there is a few examples
of games that had lower Metacritic in
the 70s wasn't add I don't know what 70
something or like maybe it was low 80s
but yeah but hey you know what you know
why though right you know why Metacritic
is is is so big now I think it's clear
because all of the other narratives are
dead besides console sales console sales
is the only narrative they still have
but all of the other narratives power
and all this you know Metacritic is is
something they really they're really
focusing
on you know because that's all they have
besides Council sales so that's why
Metacritic means so much
now yeah and I agree I I think that look
you could go out there you could say
this you could say that but my thing is
just like let it be consistent because
when death stranding got put game in the
air these same people saying oh it's a
good game deserves there it's just like
it blows my mind like he a 82 people in
the chat you know I'm I'm I'm put you
guys the work people in the chat is
there any other games in those two that
has been put in the Game of the Year
conversation with nomination that scored
low on Metacritic and to me you know
I've always been this this big standard
of like we need to fix the Metacritic
system I know people say oh you know
some other opinion shouldn't should
affect you it doesn't but to me it's
like look how people look at Rotten
Tomato these days like a lot of people
do not consider it anything I don't even
hear about Rotten Tomato it's just
because people don't respect Rotten
Tomato I personally feel like Metacritic
is on that line it's about to get to the
point where no one respects it and I'm
sitting here screaming from the top of
my lugs let's fix this before it gets
out of hand and people like why do you
care and I'm like because people should
care that the the review system is
broken it should be something people
look at and for some reason I don't
blame these websites for taking
advantage of the Metacritic system I I
blame Metacritic system for allowing
them to go this far with it oh uh didn't
gushima get nominated to that was 83
yeah so it's just like and people had no
problem ghost be in there none
none I it's like I get it like I do I
get why people get frustrated with the
matter and and it's just like you know I
find it like the same way when it comes
to you know any issue in society like to
me if we don't speak out on it they'll
literally never get fixed it will be the
same way it is between now and then uh
you know it's like I understood why
people were complaining about the ad on
Call of Duty do I think it was a little
too much yeah you know I don't think
that justifies and you know that's
automatically going to mean people are
going to abuse the system but I can
understand why people would say yo if we
give them an inch here they're going to
eventually use this for a mile later so
that made more sense to me now people
sitting there acting like look it they
were literally just advertising
something that you might want to play so
uh you know I think as long as it stays
there it's fine uh but if it goes beyond
that like imagine if like the
advertising it started becoming about
money and not what we want to play that
that's the thing it's like I'm sitting
here looking at this and I'm like all
right you know to me that was put up
there for are benefit yo Call of Duty's
coming out you might want to play it
that wasn't really put up there on a
monetary value kind of thing but if we I
understand why people are like we can't
let it get that way where people are
like we're just going to start you know
when you pop on your Xbox first thing
pops up is you know like a KFC ad or a
door Dash ad like like that is where I'm
like yo we don't want it to get that
far um as long as it's skippable man I
don't care bro
now if it's like YouTube where you gotta
watch for at least five 10 seconds
that's the
issue that's that's just me yeah what do
you think King me personally I feel that
you know um advertisement has to come
from someplace I don't want to be
playing the game and to pop up in the
game yeah now that's all right right you
don't remember that time we went through
it was a it was a it was a while ago but
we would have brand endorsements inside
games you know don't remember it's still
in a sports well well in sports games
it's
natural like if if if you're playing
Madden and you see logos or you playing
uh uh you know what is it football
manager something like that see banners
this they are supposed to be inclusives
of real world things true so before we
would have advertisements inside games
and they made sense sports games make
sense it does but then when we were
playing like shooter games and stuff
like that you see you run past a Taco
Bell yeah or or or you run past the KFC
and then it be it started to become
intrusive because you understood that
they paid for um product placement Like
Crazy Taxi crazy ta remember that you
had to drive people off a Pizza Hut so
okay so that's what I'm talking about
right so I'm talking about that and we
had got to a point where excuse me
excuse me we had got to a point where it
started becoming oversaturated and we
didn't know how to monetize it as a as a
a whole as an industry we didn't know
how to monetize that and then they
rained it they pulled it in rains they
listened to us they did we didn't like
the product placement being intrusive in
the games that we were playing we we
like the mythical world that they made a
like could you imagine playing Final
Fantasy and you see a McDonald's like
that's that's what I'm talking about
that's that's that's what I'm talking
about so I don't want product placement
and ads like that Spider-Man is the most
egregious because I'm playing Spider-Man
and Miles pops up with his last suit out
of no place where did you make this suit
from and they they make mention of the
suit oh that's a new suit oh yeah
because Spidey had a new suit oh you got
a new suit but you wearing Adidas boo I
got those adidas Boost I'm looking at
your feet bro then I'm looking at the
suit and addict said oh the suit is ugly
and they force you to wear this suit
it's not an optional suit and it's
certain segments of the game like
certain segments of the game you can't
change from Spider-Man suit you got to
wear certain suits and one segment of
the game I didn't know if I was able to
change back but didn't allow me to
change the suit at that one segment I
don't know afterwards I didn't care I
started changeing the suit after the
game was over
but that was egregious I don't even know
how Spider-Man is supposed to stick to
the wall with boo on his feet but I'm
just
saying yeah that that that that product
placement was a little bit of Greedious
and I saw people giving push back on
it you know I I might be in a minority
here um right now if they do something
like drop a ad in the middle of a game
yeah like while I'm playing and the
commercial comes on that's that's no
that's unacceptable but me it doesn't
bother me um like somebody mentioned
Midnight Club that game had prob of
placement all through the game from
Billboards to
gas stations like you said sports games
it makes sense because that's like real
life you see you know advertisements
everywhere but me personally like Crazy
Taxi didn't bother me at all y yo pick
up these people from Pizza Hut drop
those people off at KFC I thought it was
cool especially at that time to see real
life stories in a video game now I just
feel just me it doesn't bother me as
much
because just say like for example Call
of Duty is a big fight what was that
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 were
fighting like in a shopping strip bro
they didn't have like names like
McDonald's and stuff but it was so cool
to me that you were fighting in a fast
food restaurant does it matter if it's
like a Taco Bell or something no
technically no but it wouldn't bother me
personally if it was a Taco Bell I just
um but it gotta make sense yeah as long
as it makes sense yeah I don't I
remember people complaining that they
were looking into
like doing ads and games that like when
it come to like on billboards and stuff
where they can like put like switch the
ads throughout time on like Billboards
on like um on games like let's say
you're Spider-Man and you're flying
around there's a billboard there they'll
switch what that billboard is I don't
mind stuff like that because I don't
feel like that's invasive I I I feel
like that is actually that's the most
realistic [__] that you could possibly
have that that's what happens in real
life like but what I don't like is I
don't want I don't want Ro ads that's
the number one thing I'll step my foot
down I don't want to sit there uh start
this cut scene and right before we about
to find out like a key twist and like
Spider-Man they roll a 10sec KFC app now
that's unacceptable that adding that
will be unacceptable right there my
brother could you imagine that you about
to cut scene that would be unacceptable
that's what I'm talking about yeah right
and we get that right now like somebody
uh uh we had ham solo on and he was
talking about if you have Paramount it
do that right you going you I have
haven't had commercials in my shows for
forever oh yeah they're getting
ridiculous with it now now hold on I got
par they don't do that with me but you
got the premium bro
PR don't shame me bro don't shame me it
is it is intrusive and the reason I'll
say it's intrusive with that is because
Netflix used to have a base thing that
was with no ads and then they had the
higher tiers but now they removed the
middle the no ads that was higher than
the first one because they either want
you with ads or want you paying premium
premium thing with 4K and everything to
me that is that is really shady no but
we're talking like a $10 difference in
subscription though we're not get on a
lay down though that's okay I don't I
don't mind like an
8.99 how much is it worth to you though
that's I'm tell you go ahead adct CU go
go ahead cuz I'mma tell you exactly what
happened to me but go ahead adct thing
is you shouldn't you shouldn't do slidy
tactics like that like to me if that
tier is existing that tier should be
around you shouldn't just get rid of it
because you think it's going to make you
more money in the long run like I can
understand to me putting just putting an
ad one that's at like I think it's like
$7.99 that's fine because then you're
going to get those lower-end people that
don't mind to watch ads but it's like
okay now they're like okay you know what
since since we got the ad one there you
know I don't like these people on this
you know I I want them off this middle
tier I want them on that 4K I want them
paying me $20 a month it's like $24 a
month or something like that and to me
like if you're doing slimy stuff like
that now if you just left the middle
tier you just kept it rolling you kept
it rolling like peacock they just
recently the reason because initially
they their their standard T tier had no
ads and then they did another tier above
that that had ads that have no ads and
what's funny is they kept you in that
first one they're like yo you know I
know you were paying $8.99 with no ads I
know you were but you know what we gonna
do we gonna downgrade you to the ad one
there is no like to me that's that's
slimy because originally that's a
different I had no ads on peacock and
then just randomly it just start that's
a little different that's a little
listen listen all these companies in the
beginning need to get you in right and
at the end of the day let's let's let's
let's keep it a buck how many people was
rocking with the noads we was right and
they really want you in the highest tip
before for them to operate and give you
the quality that you feel that you
deserve and that you want to see they
need to operate at the higher uh bracket
all companies do right I don't know why
PlayStation even offers a lower tier I
don't even know why they don't want you
there they put everything in an upper
tier give only the upper teer that's it
that's my opinion of it um because I
don't see the difference in that Netflix
same way so many people was sharing
Netflix accounts y'all hurt the market I
don't want to hear none of y'all cry
about oh Netflix is doing this and that
to me when you was on your cousin
uncle's nephews uh agree with you I
agree with you see and to me I don't
like that either it's like look like you
you were very clear yo okay we $799 on
Netflix back in the day you can have up
to two people then they started
realizing people were just sharing two
accounts okay we'll let you share but
you got to pay us more money for that
four 4v4 one man you can have four
people but you paying us so people
started paying them okay take it take
the four and they're like you know what
we changed our mind we don't want you
have them four they gotta be in the same
household like that's right I mean I'm
down with that because okay so you go
look at your numbers and you pushing
your numbers because you want to get
movies you want to get sponsors you want
to do this all right you have 40 million
people watching your
joint but only 10 million is
paying hell got Swit it up right now
now here's the thing with with
situations like that my only issue is is
just Netflix because Netflix are like
they were giving you the option to pay
to have more people on your account to
me you can't sit there and give people
an option like that and then L like
years later realize no we don't want you
having that option same dude ain't in
well I feel you on that but at the same
time you took on that that was your
choice N I don't like what he did that's
why he's fired he got to go who who I'm
walk in the building why I got 40
million watching and only 10 million
paying that's BS I'm not doing that
that's like you living in your household
you paying all the bills and you got
four muches in your house ain't gonna
happen bro it ain't gonna happen right
bro get a job today King Day man we know
we got to realize bro we have like I pay
for four different accounts that can
stream Netflix simultaneously right
right I I pay for it though so what K is
saying it was one point like you say 40
million 10 million pay for it come on
man let I mean listen I I understand
Netflix is a successful business but we
gotta we gotta see how Joey Pon what do
this conversation the Video Game Awards
nothing
we literally somehow we got somehow we
got into ads and then ads went to
Netflix and the Netflix went into like
practices on Netflix my bad let's let's
reail let's let's let's I already said
what I felt y'all gotta get to
y' d d how do you feel about the game
awards and if Starfield is not there
what do you think is going to take it
place first of all I think Starfield
should be nominated um I don't think it
will win cuz I feel that this is Bal G
three year for whatever reason you
playong who me no I play so the hell
with that stop
voting I'm just going by you know no no
don't do that don't do that I have play
people jumping off a bridge you gonna
jump off a bridge too I'm do what your
mom told you because my mom told me the
same thing nah man no I ain't voting for
that all right but um yeah I believe
Starfield should be there man that game
speak say with your chest man bro listen
listen this is a Oreo cookie let's go
like but there but there's the games
their previous games were nominated for
Game of the Year their previous games
were mid low 90s even with all the bugs
and those games were I don't know which
one won I believe one of them won back
in the day so why would this game a
brand new IP from Todd Howard and his
team the game is incredible why would
this game not be um nominated at least
nominated for Game of the Year yeah yes
I understand Zelda is is is there okay
cool that's that's a sequel to A long
long franchise um people say Resident
Evil 4 that's a remake people say hogo
Legacy yes that's a great game but it's
based on a huge franchise um you know we
think about like what's some of the
other ones that people saying gonna be
nominated Allan way I don't know that's
a sequel so this is a brand new
IP and I believe the game should 100% be
nominated will it be I I I think will if
it's not
nominated oh
man yeah you know what's funny is kid
Smo said if Starfield is not nominated
uh he he's picking up his pitch for it
and I was like I'm sure pay him no M man
once he said Apple need to buy Xbox get
out of here so so he credibility after
that one bro he said that and I was like
look I was like I won't pick up a
pitchfork unless I see and you know and
don't know where I'm going with this
unless I see that eyes sore known as
Final Fantasy 16 on that damn list and
not Starfield if I see Final Fantasy 16
on that list when Starfield isn't that's
what I'm like okay now we going we if
that happens add if Final Fantasy 16 is
on that nomination list and Starfield
lizard I'mma pick up my pitch for it too
because bro so hold on hold up hold up
let's say Final Fantasy 16 is on there
are you are you boycotting the the video
game of Wars cuz no I'm not I have and
Starfield is not yes yep so you won live
streaming or anything n see I can't do
that because king would kill me if I
didn't if I didn't show up to
that um me me personally if Final
Fantasy is there I can't
boycott that thing because of where I am
in in in the community right so even if
I don't agree with what homeboy is
talking about or even if I don't agree
with what his show was talking about if
I'm there at the show I can ask
hard-hitting questions I I can ask the
questions and then he can deflect he
could play around it he can do whatever
but as long as um our community get a
chance to ask those questions on
why then I believe that our voices need
to be heard because I think if we turn
the mute button on him and we don't give
him a a chance to explain himself or
explain the process then we're doing
more harm than good because we're at a
point now where we have a ability to
have these conversations with these
individuals we could sit in rooms with
these individuals I've been in rooms
with him so these conversations should
be had and if they aren't had then we're
doing ourself a disservice for the next
game that we feel that should be
nominated and maybe a review process
need a restructuring I just I don't I
felt like Final Fantasy
16 you know might have been a good
action adventure game but I didn't see
it as that I saw as a Final Fantasy game
and to me the key components that made
Final Fantasy was lacking in that game
if you like that game chances are to me
and I know it's not everyone but the
majority of the people that love the
older final fantasies they did not like
16 uh now obviously that's not everybody
I'm sure there there's some weirdos in
the chat that liked it and like Final
Fantasy and you know it is what it is at
this point guys you know I'm gonna have
to I'm might have to look at your final
fantasy card you know you GNA have to
put them stats up you got to post that
[__] on Twitter where is these stats I
gotta see you had it will be Final
Fantasy 7 8 10 and then maybe I'll start
to consider your your opinion when it
comes to Final Fantasy 16 as a final
fantasy now you I take your opinion if
if Final Fantasy 16 is a good game in
general but if you did not like fi if
you liked Final Fantasy 16 and you claim
that you was a fan of older final
fantasies I I I'm going need to check
them cards I just just it's it's just
how it
is ever since King met me he knows I've
been about these Final Fantasy streets
facts all right so you know there a't
much to talk about when it comes to that
you know I'm very curious to see what
happens in the future I think uh I think
next week's gonna be a very interesting
week I I really oh I'm gonna make one
hell of a video what hell of a video all
right so let's uh let's get into these
super chats real quick we got a f a $2
Super Chat from Marvin ginyard MBG won't
quit gaming he's all comeing no bite I
agree I agree did you see that King did
you see he said if uh he would he he
would not game anymore under if if XBox
wins because they just buying
everything um when so I guess he's out
watching Marvel movies well I don't I
don't care about no it's the same thing
it's like Marvel was dominating because
they bought everything well his his
opinion is isn't valid because when Sony
was block back blackballing people and
and and boxing people out the industry
doing
dirtyhands and and really locking people
out they locked Sega out you know they
did these things they locked Nintendo
out there a reason why Nintendo didn't
have third party support it was what
what you thought that people just woke
up and said N I don't want to mess with
Nintendo like you you got to do your
homework do your homework bro like you
guys it hit different when you read it
hit different when you you actually
research something so when people are
disingenuous with their agendas you
ain't saving Kong and I don't care if
you don't play all any game ever again I
don't care if you take your controller
and throw it away I don't care if you
break your PlayStation gaming is gonna
continue without you it was there before
you and it's gonna continue without you
just because you got a YouTube channel
and you think that your opinion sways
anybody feelings no they heard you when
you said don't go by Call of Duty and it
went out and purchased Call of Duty
nobody listening to you bro you just
entertainment for the moment so all I uh
dealing in oh I'mma do this if this
happens stop dealing in infinites and
and making concrete uh declarations you
don't have to if if XBox win you'll be
disappointed I'mma still game yeah but
I'mma be disappointed that's it it's
it's like that they it's like I'm a
[__] I'mma Be quiet but I'mma still
[__]
it's like equivalent to like hating on
Destiny but playing it offline yes dudes
do it all the time have a whole stock
account you don't think I know half the
dudes that come at me but don't come at
me with their real account they say
something stupid they got like two
followers on Twitter No but I know I
know the individuals because the stuff
that they say I'm like I know who you
are right all right but you don't say it
with your real account because you know
I I catch you in traffic right so so
it's it's just the equivalent of that
that fraudery these dudes are frauds you
can hold them to it I'mma tell him
Microsoft is going to win this
generation Microsoft is going to bury
you dudes Microsoft is going to buy
everything out and you're gonna sit
there and still gain clip this bring it
back show it to him later you're gonna
play Yo clip this put it on Twitter use
that clip feature after the podcast
we're going to goad move on $5 Super
Chat from r d g uh let me go back to
this what's up guys a high Metacritic
score does not make a good game a game
good there are 90 plus games that I find
boring and regret buying uh I would
actually agree on a couple different
standards you know a lot of people
didn't like the last uh metal gear solid
five and it got really high I hated it
bro I hated it and to me that Metacritic
that Metacritic score is way easier man
at the people think oh absolutely it's
way easier to manipulate than people
think even just by fear you know oh you
know I get I get Spider-Man 2 all these
bugs I'm still gonna give it a nine out
of 10 because I'm worried maybe you know
if I come too hard on this game for the
bugs you know
Sony Sony isn't going to you know mess
with me in the future yeah absolutely
100% because you saw what they did with
uh Survivor because they gave Horizon
forbidden West a bad score and they
didn't send them any more games to
review and and and Survivor gave
Spider-Man 9 out of 10 I wonder if he
they did that to get in son's great good
graces or they believe that it is what
it is I'm not gonna tell people's
individual reviews pixel bit G uh been a
member for 46 months man that's almost
as long as being and my girl been
together final F that's crazy you you
became a member around the time I got
with my girl uh Final Fantasy 15 had a
couple of noodles signs and trucks you
could eat from yep I just saw somebody
uh my boy Joey just sent it to me y uh
you gotta find out Monster Energy some
Efron uh bentes he said I remember True
Crimes New York was sponsored by
Motorola and you hear hello Mo Moto all
the time yeah I do remember that I
remember that got a $2 subscribe from
Sir X-Man streaming ads came from no
one's watching cable TV and you know
what's funny look I do agree that the
price is going up is starting to mimic a
little bit on TV but he's like you don't
have to get here's the thing you don't
have to get all these Services you don't
you can literally just get one that has
the hottest stuff on watch what you want
to watch and then cancel that move on to
the next one that has the hottest stuff
for the next sure sometimes if you want
to watch multiple shows you have to have
multiple subscriptions uh you know going
at the same time but most of the time
and me King we watch a lot of TV shows
and stuff it's very rare that there's
two or three big popular shows on
multiple different networks most of the
time they're pretty spread out the
problem is adct people are lazy and they
get a they get a service and they forget
about it and when they do remember then
it has something that they want to see
so then they're trapped in this
Perpetual cycle that's why there's apps
out there that that let you know how
long you've been watching certain stuff
or how many times you open up an and if
you want to delete that service off so
you know because people are absolutely
lazy and and it's uh purchase and forget
we do that a lot so I I don't I don't
begrudge a lot of people for being weary
and what's going on because sometimes
people get caught up in life and you
forget okay yeah so will you uh here I'm
gonna get the super chat I gotta do
something real quick uh uh DT will you
get that super
the angry therapist with the two RoboCop
should get a
nomination it should get a nomination
for best Nostalgia game bro yeah I
haven't played it yet man I bought it
but I haven't played it yet yo D I was
watching um somebody playing is and
excuse me I'm sorry I forgot who exactly
who you were but at night sometimes I'm
I'm going through people's channels you
got like four or five viewers I'm
jumping in I'm watching I'm getting a
like and he had had like probably like
six viewers watching and he was playing
Robocop and I'm so thirsty to see the
game if they did it right and the level
of dismemberment and death and stuff
like that is true to the TV show or
movie and I was like yo this is so dope
the likeness of of his partner
everything Ed 209 everything looked
really good so I'm like it it was like a
little time capsule for me
nice all right so um I can't wait to
check it have that be down you going to
have some fun yeah we got nominations
should be based on impact and Innovation
people talked about Spider-Man 2 Final
Fantasy 16 two weeks and then they uh
think these games should be there I
agree see here's the thing I've always
thought that you know they they they'll
put like stuff like best game of 20 uh
of 2023 the best racer like to me game
of the year is what impacted the
industry the most what was talked about
the most what took the Twitter uh you
know streets the most what took YouTube
the most like when Elden ring came out
it shut the whole internet down that why
ELD ring won game of the year when
OverWatch came out even though if you
didn't agree that that game should have
won game of the year when OverWatch came
out it shut the internet down like
because it had impact I don't personally
think the best game of the year doesn't
always necessarily have to be the best
game that came out this year it has to
be the most impactful most of the time
they're two and two together they're
going to be the best game it's gonna be
the most impactful in a in a modly
positive way I think you that the only
problem that you're having here is you
want people to be uh clear-minded
thinking individuals and not thinking
with try to save Kong mentality because
both of those games that he just put up
are PlayStation games or games that are
on the PlayStation platform only at this
moment and those individuals feel
entitled to have their games rated to 10
and be in Game of the Year nominations
every year they feel some sense of uh
accomplishment that their games are
nominated and their games are rated high
they feel some sense of of
accomplishment because they feel that
they are part of an elitist group maybe
in their lives they don't have uh stuff
to look forward to but these games give
them some form of validation and I think
y'all should really take a look at
yourselves and say I'm not going to tie
myself down to our identity of a
corporation that can disappear at any
moment I know a lot of Y guys say oh you
you you Champion Xbox you this that and
and the third with Xbox yeah Xbox can go
away just like everybody else bro I
Champion NEC I Champion a lot of people
but um at the end of the day don't tie
your identity to a box and if a box
doesn't get nominated or a game doesn't
get nominated from your box you don't
lose anything all you did was
participate by
purchasing yeah and that's why I feel
like you know even like I don't know
maybe maybe it's just me but I felt like
this the Spider-Man 2 like Twitter talks
and YouTube talks it kind of not didn't
die down but it toned down really fast
because it was broken it felt like a
week and it was just everyone's talking
maybe it's because it was around like
Allen wake 2 so it was easier to jump to
another game quicker but I felt like
Boulders gate people talked about that
for like a month straight Starfield
people talk that for like a month
straight I felt like I felt like Zelda
was dead in like a week yeah yeah I
agree with what you saying because
eldering I'm not a fan of from software
games but the hype surrounding that game
and what people was talking about noing
I bought it because I was like I gotta
try this damn game um King did the same
thing D I don't play those games I ended
that game I know life I I can tell you I
was playing that game so hard you
finished it yeah we we have a uh
something on the patreon where and the
members were it was I I joined one of
King's uh he was fighting a boss he was
fighting a mage in the giant Tower and I
was just doing because I was so high
level she couldn't hurt me but she could
just mess up King and I sit you're going
around I'm literally just
emoting yeah he's just doing weird stuff
in the background that the game what I'm
I'm waiting for the DLC yeah I was
playing the game so hard DT I got to a
point where I started looking at builds
and when you know when a game consumes
your soul is when you're sleeping and
you're thinking about said game you wake
up and you're thinking about the game
you go to work you can't wait to get
back home for the game and I'm thinking
about builds and how to get this weapon
or how to do this and I'm looking for
DLC for this game I thought this year
was GNA be it so I hope at the game
awards we get DLC for Elder ring I hope
I pray because I think the game is fat
yeah then we got bone bone slave with
the $2 Super Chat IOP baby let's go
appreciate charie family B what's good
baby I definitely appreciate all the uh
support so let's let's move on to Xbox
visiting blizzard because it it normally
I wouldn't talk about something like
this but this was this was interesting
because even mik abar came out and was
like essentially and I obviously I'm
paraphrasing but he was like Phil pretty
much came in here and said you guys are
getting your Independence back like now
now it's no it's not Activision Blizzard
King to me the energy they're throwing
out it's Activision then blizzard there
then King like it's three companies work
they're not working together anymore not
necessarily not working together I'm
sure they'll still work together because
they probably have really good chemistry
but like these companies aren't like I
felt like if something would happen in
Call of Duty I guarantee you blizzard
was on on a phone call I need you to
help me with this and I'm not saying
that could still couldn't happen but I
do think these studios are going to be
able to actually work on their own stuff
from now on like they're not going to
have to just off of what's going on
they'll be able to work on their own
game so King what do you think about
that man what I personally feel like
blizzard is going to be one of Xbox's
top
Studios well with Mikey bar in charge I
don't know if he sticks around any
further but the the ability to have the
freedom to financially move how you want
to move and not saying that Activision
didn't have the bread Activision had the
bread to move around however they wanted
to move because they locked up into
having Call of Duty turned into one of
the most successful juggernauts in the
industry right now then when they switch
to war zone you had that war zone
reoccurring money that can fund a lot of
projects I think he sees the level of
Freedom with the hierarchy that's in
charge Bobby KK was worried only about
Call of Duty and everything else can
happen after the fact I
think uh
Phil thinks more about the broader and
looks at blizzard and says okay blizzard
what's IPS that you got that you wanted
to work on and you don't have to be
holding to a schedule that has to tie
down to Call of Duty because Call of
Duty must come out every year it must
come out at a certain time so the
schedule is this and you got to figure
out how to fit your games in the
schedule whenever is a downtime from war
zone to DLC to to to whatever even
though your game doesn't compete
necessarily in its same genre your game
competes in the same building so they
don't want an overshadow say look at the
downtrends okay so your game can slot
into this month from this month we're
gonna have a downtime let's put your
game in there and I think now they don't
have that restriction any longer because
Microsoft will still keep over with Call
of Duty it still be all over the place
but the fact of the matter is they
recognize blizzard and King is separate
entities that bring something different
to the pot that they are looking for
because they went specifically for these
three companies that are in one company
to get unique stuff from all three of
them yeah and I think to me what's
What's Happening Here is I personally
feel like Blizzard's always been mad
talented I just think you know because
they were answering the Activision at
the end of the day yeah but now they are
their own company and I feel like
there's less red tape you know I think
there's more creative freedom because
they because you you you reach out to to
Activision to Bobby like yo I want to
because they because they it was rumored
that you know uh Jason shrier said that
Starcraft might not be an RTS you know
you you go up to uh to to Bobby like yo
you know we make decent money from
Starfield uh Starcraft is RTS we kind of
want to do something different with it
is it making Call of Duty money uh
probably not out to get no then no you
yeah work on what you work on OverWatch
making us money go do that like and to
me now it's going to be freed up a
little bit because they're there there's
not going to it's not necessarily
they're not going to care about the
money because they're definitely going
to care about the money but I feel like
you're not going to be compared to Call
of Duty every time you try to do
something what you think D yeah that's a
great Point um I believe um you know I
don't know how you guys are at your jobs
so you know I know King you got your own
thing um but morale is very important at
your job right my job they're always
talking about morale they have these
surveys to you know see hey go pacce why
don't you do me a favor and go ahead and
get out of here punk
um what did he say y he XBox ain't got
nothing he coming here talking that
trash boy well I mean soon they have
everything and you GNA have nothing to
say like God bless stick around watch
the party baby I don't ever want to
block you I want you to stick around and
respect we gonna make you bend the knee
if you don't bend it now you gonna bend
it later get your knees ready
pause so like I was saying so like Adam
like you just made a great Point um
maybe because like maybe when blizzard
became part of Activision they kind of
you know like you said maybe they will
compare certain numbers to Call of Duty
maybe they will compare certain stuff to
Activision themselves but now since
they're on Microsoft under Xbox maybe
Phil Spencer just wants them to do their
own thing maybe he might give them a
little C blanch to to do what they want
to do not full C Blan but you know just
just do what y'all want to do we trust
you guys we want you guys to be your own
thing even though you're all up on the
Xbox it was activism blizzard King
they're all up on the Xbox now so hey
just do your thing uh Mike iara he seems
to be happy well I guess maybe um so
we'll see what happens with blizzard I'm
not really into their games right now
but because I'm a bot I plan on getting
trying to get into some of their games
in the future
so I think the morale it looks look
seems high at Xbox game studios you know
we see seeing a lot of
promotions um and look man they said
they didn't like some of those
promotions they thought the the
promotion was diversity higher I saw
that that's why these guys pieces are
trash this why guys like go par all his
block his punk ass you know I don't care
I don't care about his opinion I don't
care about
nothing
I want him to stick around my mama
always told me make your enemies watch
you
eat we eating good over here baby hey
tomorrow wildart come out Game Pass we
ain't got games y'all really ain't got
no games that seven hours is over for
Spiderman that buggy mess get back to
business hey I guess I might be a little
different my told me if your enemy is
the Ops don't have don't let them around
here
my mama say wound him so his friends can
come pick him up and you can take his
friends out
too that's how snipers do we leave you
right there boom and you down we just go
put you in the leg just in the leg
baby he's like use him as a use him as a
uh bait as
bait what we do in fortnite we got
different
methods that's why we have different te
we snip him on site n you know when you
in field with me when I hit you in the
shoulder and you behind the wall and you
looking around and you talking on your
radio I'm pinned down I need backup we
gonna take all your backup out first
man it's crazy man it just you know
there's a lot of things that's going on
in the industry uh you know we we we
definitely going to have to I I think
blizzard is going to be a fantastic
company I think they're going to
especially flourish on XB yeah I also
think that you know Starcraft is is a
different game you know they might make
it like a mass effect type of Style game
or maybe even just make like a really
nice like uh you know action-based game
off of it there's a lot of options that
they can do and I think that's the part
that people forget is like Activision
and blizzard especially King King is
just doing King but Activision and
blizzard they were kind of not doing
anything extra anymore they they weren't
you know trying anything new and to me
it was never going to change because
they were making too much money and
under Xbox they could take more risks
sure are they going to let them be like
don't make Call of Duty no Call of Duty
is still gonna come out but but I do
think that they might do a different
approach on Call of Duty uh so it is
what it is when it comes to that you
know I think that uh we we'll go ahead
and get these super chats real quick we
got a $2 Super Chat from THX
11138 Microsoft was trying to acquire
blizzard and OG Xbox days I did hear
about that I did hear about that did you
guys ever hear about that Microsoft was
trying to buy trying to B everybody man
they trying to buy Nintendo so I
wouldn't be surprised by that yo yo got
him by hook a crook son you in the book
son we got you son I don't care how you
slice it son you part of Xbox family
King while I'm reading these super chats
you need to get to that that title man
you need to get to that title on your
channel I did it already oh okay okay I
when I mute myself that's what I was
doing I got we got a $10 super cha HD
did you all check out the Sarah Bond
recent interview I would love to hear
your thoughts I I couldn't find get a
chance to watch I put it in the chat I
put in the chat saying like she had a
recent interview and I went on YouTube
to look for it because I was GNA make
that my video today but when I I could
only find an interview that's was like a
month old like so it's I think that's
the one I think that's talk about the
one from Gamespot right delilo yeah C
because to me it seemed like saw so many
clips and stuff I figured it was like
done yesterday or today no um okay so
you guys know how it I didn't want to go
out there and quote something that
happened a month ago people like adct
you looking at the wrong interview like
no no um well this this uh interview
went up by LS Joshua Gutierrez uh from
uh what is this site from Gamespot uh
you know how Xbox game pass succeeded
according to Microsoft and you know Xbox
Sarah Bond had study services like
Netflix and Spotify listen her diverse
background allows her to have the
ability to be flexible because she came
from T-Mobile and she was Best in Class
she was best in brightest and I
explained that in my video If y if any
of y'all checked out my video on Xbox
Frontline uh yesterday that I dropped uh
it went into uh people talking about a
diversity higher how I I felt as a woman
of color y'all don't really understand
exactly the obstacles that this woman
has to jump through and go through to to
where she has to be so if you thought it
was a diversity high you're out of your
mind this is a white man's dominated
industry right and I and I had that told
to me by people that are in the industry
that are happen to be of that persuasion
right so that's any female that you see
in any of these positions so if you
think anything is given to them you're
out of your mind right especially being
head of Xbox you got to be out of your
mind but the fact of the matter is this
go look at her credentials um with that
interview and I'm glad the interview
came out a day after my video because it
it eloqua the tenacity that her team had
they looked at Game Pass and said was it
a viable option was it something that
they needed to have because will people
purchase they had the hard-hitting
questions are these questions like is
Game Pass something that is going to
sustain itself do people want to
purchase have physical or have other
means in getting games or would they be
in a subscription service so the
analytics proved her to be right and the
fact that her track record showed you
Game Pass is a success and stuff has
happened the team around her helped
cultivate a lot of things so if you
thought somebody made it into a position
that prominent if you think these these
conglomerates is giving out checks to
people that that big those checks just
because your skin color you're out of
your mind they would rather have ai
running stuff and save those checks
opposed to having somebody oh just
because you got color this is not
McDonald's bro and we don't have a a
manager just because he's hispanic in
his Hispanic area that's not this be
real and and stop using your your
insecurities your misogynistic
Tendencies and your inability to see
past your own brow to to formulate
opinions that should not come out of
your mouth yeah and not to mention like
you know people people sitting there
well what I don't like is like it
doesn't matter it's like when it comes
to because I was talking to my friend
and we were talking about the uh you
know what's going on with um that movie
what's the Spider-Man uh movie with the
the female Spiderman oh you talking
about into the spb Madam web oh mean
Madam web yeah and I was talking to him
you know this the the the crew that was
on it I was like that sounds like a
solid movie and it's sad because it's
like I feel like there is a lot of stuff
going on that you know people uh stick
to some kind of narrative because of
that's what they feel like the social
aspects want but I feel like people are
starting to snipe that no matter what it
is like it it doesn't matter who get
tired it's a diversity higher it doesn't
matter what movie comes out has a female
lead it's it's pandering like sometimes
things just happen because they're good
movies or good people at what they do it
doesn't but but the problem is I think
it's happening so much that people are
just putting it all together it's like
it's not it's not a it's not a red it's
not a white and black thing like there
is stuff that's in the middle like when
when it comes to movies and and I'm
gonna say this right because I heard
people saying it with black
panther Ryan cougler wanted to replace
black panther right Disney didn't want
to replace him now in the comic book sh
does take up the mantle of the Black
Panther when tala becomes
the um The Keeper of the dead right he
he becomes the protector of the dead and
Shiri becomes the Black Panther in this
movie in that movie they accelerated
that all right what I don't like is when
they gender swap a character just for
the sake of gender swapping a character
like they did in Taskmaster Taskmaster
is a male character Taskmaster powers
are done in a way that
is um he has a photogenic memory that he
can mimic anybody's movements and they
removed that from it they fundamentally
changed the character and then they
gender swapped the character that's
where I had a problem and what made it
worse is Taskmaster is the one that
showed up in um black widow right so
it's like that was a prominently like
female cast so it's like instead of you
know having Taskmaster a man they're
like let's just switch him into a woman
for no reason but the thing is you can't
have a woman beating on a man and you
can't have a man beating on a woman
because now in
I think about that that's probably why
they did right now in this society that
we live in right now where everybody's
so sensitive and they skin is so thin
that we can't have actual fight scenes
that show you that the Black Widow can
take down any man woman or child with no
problem but we gotta have it oh pit a
woman against a woman because it's more
palatable to the audience I don't
believe in that you what's crazy
remember back in the day and I know
we're getting off Ted a little bit when
like black widow was like tied to the
chair and all those dudes were they're
trying to interrogate her and then she
got what she wanted from them and she's
like and she got like a call out of her
ear but she's like I'll be there in 10
and like she just whooped all of them it
didn't matter like it's like but I feel
like that was the old Marvel like that
that we'll get into this next topic
because uh yeah it's just I feel like
that conversation ain't gonna end well
for anyone uh you know it is what it is
uh at this point it's like either you
like it or you don't like it like
all right so let's let's talk about GTA
5 um six six GTA 6 yeah it's five's been
around so long I'm confusing the two GT
GTA 6 has officially been confirmed that
it's going to get announced next month
and most likely the Video Game Awards
I'd be very surprised if it wasn't the
Video Game Awards they say early
December and the Video Game Awards is
usually early December right I think
it's sixth yeah so that's I remember
correctly people in the chat tell me if
it's a sixth or
not yeah yeah so it's just like do you
think that the obviously this is this is
going to be like a huge moment in the
gaming it's been long time people been
wanting this but I kind of feel like in
me personally like the hype for me is
down like it's just like so many years
so many years of GTA 5 online and and
it's just like I'm not even excited for
six anymore like it just I feel like so
many years have went by I obviously I'm
still going to play but but like as of
right now now we haven't seen the
trailer uh GTA 5's trailer did a really
good job hyping me up into that game uh
so I'm assuming hoping I'm GNA get
something similar but I'm kind of
curious on your guys's thing like how
what are where are you at right now with
GTA6 you know we'll start with dirt yeah
I'm I'm hyped for it man um listen I was
scrolling my timeline on X and I'm
listen I follow a lot of sports stuff a
lot of NBA people they were talking
about GTA
six Sports guys was talking about GTA
6 this game is going to man I'm hyped
for it because I felt that GTA 5 was a
freaking Masterpiece the only thing I
hate that I did I played it on the PS4
because at the time they had on games I
said no man I need to buy something for
this damn console wish I would have
bought it on Xbox but I um the game is
going to be massive and adct I mean I'm
hyped for it and I'm hyped before the
trailer one they're going back to Vice
City AKA Miami yeah that's going to be
nice I like Vice City um I love I love
the LA s San Andreas but I also love
Vice City um they're gonna have two
protagonist supposedly brother and
sister I can't wait for it man you know
we saw some leak leak footage of it even
the leak footage that was early look
good to me so I'm excited for the game
man I felt the GTA 5 was a masterpiece
and I'm looking forward to this one bro
so
King King King King when it comes to GTA
6 yeah I don't think we've actually
really you know talked about GTA 6 a
whole lot so I'm kind of curious what
your opinion is when it comes to GTA 6
like I don't even like five has been out
so long I didn't even meet you before
five came out so I don't even know if
you played five I assume you did but I
don't even know if you
did well well
um I played the hell out of the game I
played all the GTA um San Andreas is my
my best one fire
um remake that one bro they they need to
remake all of them and put them in a
nice package but properly a real a real
one wait a second right um because they
they did that
um I'm I don't believe I don't share
your opinion
like I don't share your opinion like
like it's died down it's just dude's
been taught to sit down and shut up and
wait for it that's what they because
gonna be worth it because it's gonna be
worth it we hope we pray I don't think
anything can live up to expectations of
what we have for um this game uh the the
league footage that I saw we would have
had this game probably this year this
would if if it would have came out this
year we could have honestly said this
would have been the greatest year in in
video game history if it would have came
out this year right um but it got pushed
back because of um the the leak and
holding them hostage and all that other
crap I'm telling you if you think the
phenomena Call of Duty of fortnite is
something when this game shows it's
going to break the Internet it's going
to break the timeline it's going to
break the zeit GES it's it's going to
and if they if they put the trailer and
then say pre-orders is
live I guarantee you it's going to sell
Million by the time you finish watching
the triller I I can guarantee you the
pre-orders alone is going to be 15 to 20
million by the time the triller is over
that's the highest grossest selling game
easily when it releases easily easily
okay um I feel you uh King ch check your
title I Chang it I'm getting what you
think to
me I'm GNA be real with you I love
Resident Evil GTA 5 like I thought GTA 5
was a fantastic game I love the story
more than anything now my brother in
there like I he got like I don't even
know how many hours in GTA V it's
ridiculous like it it's absurd he's got
like everything owns in the game like
the am of stuff that he owns in GTA 5 is
just ridiculous on the online like he
he's had well I remember one time he he
he had a glitch and he lost everything
like all the stuff in all of his his
warehouses he lost all of his like ships
and stuff or whatever it is and and he's
sitting there and he's stressed he's
like I I'm done with this game I'm like
dude call call Rockstar you know because
this ain't your fault this was a glitch
so he called Rockstar
and they didn't give him his stuff back
they gave him the amount of money he
spent to get all that stuff and I was
like you going to buy all that stuff
back he's like nah it's so many more
possibilities now he had all that money
like and he was like I don't know what
to buy first like he a know what to do
with it yeah yeah hey Hey listen I you
know what I didn't know that the PC
dudes when they okay so I didn't know
this aspect of Grand Theft photo my
stupid behind only knows the story I
don't know nothing about
huge bro bro it's is the most Innovative
thing that I've ever seen these dudes
actually use their real cell phones when
they're playing this game right and is
this one dude that GTA RPG role playing
stuff I saw NB uh uh 3mg I saw him
playing that and what was crazy is he
was he was um he was negotiating a drug
deal yeah it's crazy bro yo yo yo D I'm
watching this one guy he's a he's a
hired Hitman right hired Hitman right
they got cops they got people literally
driving around need to be cops yo but
but they know him and I heard him he he
he set a dude up here was texting he
said yo we gonna meet over here give me
the money and I want you to take I want
you to knock off this dude from me he's
at uh uh TI shop the dude's a Hitman and
he went through I said
yo I didn't know this level of the game
existed bro
that you can become your character yeah
man Hey listen they got movies on
YouTube people did twoh hour movies in
GTA 5 online okay what what what I do
want to do I hate to cut this this topic
short uh because uh D gonna have to
leave here really really soon and I just
want his initial opinions on the
Spider-Man patch uh because you know he
definitely we were one of the people
that was saying this game definitely you
know has some bugs in it and people are
calling us liars and I I I want your
opinion real quick for you head out what
is your opinion on uh them fixing uh
them putting a patch to fix issues that
apparently didn't exist well I think
it's a fake patch add
it didn't exist the bugs wasn't real the
bugs were something that people was
forcing so I don't know if you saw the
list of bug fixes is pretty is a pretty
substantial list but apparently it's a
fake ass list man I mean it's a fake ass
patch because bugs didn't exist you know
we said we were forcing
it let's let's look let's look I don't
think that's all of it is it no no it's
just one of it's just one of all right
all right so addresses an issue where
NPCs could spawn on top of each other in
boats guess that never happened I don't
know what happened with that this
doesn't exist it was force M it was for
M sure MJ could be defeated in one hit
on higher difficulty settings address
multiple issues where or hiding the HUD
could cause submissions to fa to
trigger addressing an issue where
Collision was missing on the floor in
the
harbor further addresses issues where
players could become stuck in the final
of the miracula memories addressing
issues where a player could swap
characters during the defeat sequence
how do you swap characters with
people it has no bugs adct this is a
fake patch
address is an issue where players could
be stuck walk running in a
wall addresses an issue where the wrong
Spider-Man could receive phone calls
that the player switch characters during
a car it happened that happened to me
that happened to me I got I got miles
phone calls where I was supposed to be
getting Peter phone
calls listen to this one a play uh
addressed an issue where the player
could lose the ability to jump and a
Spiderman get
address multiple issues multiple where
inputs would not register after zip uh
zipping to a
point so if you use the most basic
function in the game you could you
couldn't move anymore that that's crazy
address an issue with a game would not
properly reload after defeating by a
boss that happened to me a bunch like a
bunch that that would happened to me
address an issue where Peter Parker uh
could become stuck on a bench or railing
yeah that happened a lot too that
happened a lot too address an issue
where Spider-Man could clip through the
map and become stuck during combat yeah
hey King does this seem like does this
seem like a 10 out of 10 game I never
said it was I said it was a eight no I'm
no I'm talking about everything you seen
online bro people were trying to say
that we were forcing these it hurt my
heart it hurt my heart it hurt this
hurts my heart bro like you
don't you don't know how bad I was
champion this game in my soul like you
have no idea this hurts me so bad fact
they got the Puerto Rican flag
wrong me and dir were laughing because
we knew this was gonna happen like we
knew this this patch was gonna happen go
ahead and take off dirt so you have a
couple minutes before you get on the
other dir yo
DK all right so we got a one half of the
Oreo going Yeah man so now
just you know when you P the
top someone just took off the the black
top it's just the White and the black
yeah somebody gonna eat the top of the
cookie later my weight tace twin all
right Brothers I'll see y'all later man
the wa
brother yeah we got to do a show called
the weight T Butters the weight TW
Butters I love it
so you know I just want to point that as
like these these issues were real like
this wasn't something that was done on
purpose like these issues were real they
they actually happened that that's the
part that annoyed me King people were
acting like like the people that were
coming across these issues were forcing
it and it just wasn't the CH yo ad it's
like a dude knowing that don't want to
believe his girl is cheating like all
everybody call them telling them Yo she
cheating she out with this too like nah
not my girl nah yo until you got to see
the facts and then they show you the
facts and they could look at it and be
like no that ain't happen you making
this up that's Photoshop she ain't with
that dude until you actually physically
there it happened to me I wanted this
game to be the best I'm not gonna lie
I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna lie I I
don't care how much y'all dudes say that
you know I'm down for Xbox when it comes
to certain stuff man I'm 100% I don't
want to see a broken game ever the worst
thing in the world is you going to
purchase a game with your money and you
get home and it's not what you expect it
to be I don't ever want anyone to have
that type of experience I don't care
what side of the fence I'm on I don't
ever want that to happen and the fact of
the matter that people are in denial
over that because they want it to be
something that is not they have a
problem with their self because I'm
telling you I love the game more than
anybody else trust me when I tell you
this I have the exact Spider-Man right
here the Sony Spider-Man in the
Spider-Man suit right here I got him
right there
Statue I want I wanted it to win I
wanted it to win and I didn't accept the
fact that it lost game of the year in
2018 and I don't I probably
don't I probably don't accept it this
year
but the bugs is real the game was rushed
and we're going to have to come to the
fact that uh Sucker Punch
uh knows this uh insomnia I mean Sucker
Punch Insomniac knows this and
Insomniac uh is doing the work in the
background I had like seven patches to
the
game from when I was playing it before
this major
patch and I'm not going back to the game
I don't Platinum the game I'm not going
back to the game so whatever they do to
the game now it's it's whatever but now
Insomniac knew and and I think NE was
pushed they had to push the game out it
sucks so it it sucks that we going to
get a messed up product and then people
going to rink them over the co for
actually fixing the bad product yeah I
feel you on that all right so uh last
topic man this is gonna be a pretty
quick one and I know the the the chat is
upset about this just as much we're
gonna talky put this Call of Duty thing
me and King talked about it on IL and I
wanted um I wanted dirt but I didn't
want to keep him in here uh tell all the
way up to his other podcast I wanted him
to get a little bit of time to go get
something to drink maybe use the
bathroom you know and plus you know we
we don't have corporate Cog here
either we we we we we we we can we can
really go in no I'm just like what
look we all know we were talking earlier
about the Metacritic situation and
whether or not this whole infrastructure
needs to be rehauled I just want your
your your opinion on the m King you know
we don't have to talk about the the
direct IGN giving G uh giving Call of
Duty a four and you know at the end of
the day it's that person's opinion uh
you know I've already went over the
things I found on it you know
investigator investigator addict that's
what people are calling me uh in the
chat and I just want your over opinion
on that because to to me when I look at
something like this and I look at you
know only really reviewing Sony products
like like uh The Horizon DLC The Horizon
VR game you know reviewing god of war
and Spider-Man and the majority of the
other stuff if not all the other stuff
this person's reviewed for forceable
future was all TV stuff and it's like I
want your opinion your honest opinion on
whether or not Metacritic needs to be
rehauled well everything needs to be
fixed and changed uh due to the scale of
how games are now I don't know how old
Metacritic is and you know we came from
a time well I came from a Time where we
would get Game Informer and you know
they they would rate games on fun Factor
you know it was different things that
they would rate games on and then you
know Metacritic and stuff came out and
they changed the way that we rate games
now it was in favor for one company at a
period of time because that was used to
uh tout that that game was better than
your game and is used more now as a
bashing point to in the in the console
Wars right as a shield and a sword so
but it's going to have to change because
you brought up earlier about Rotten
Tomatoes and people stop looking
listening to Rotten Tomatoes because we
noticed an agenda against Marvel and
they would notoriously uh rate Marvel
movies lower than needed be now some of
those movies weren't good like you know
some of the movies weren't up to what we
would say is Marvel Prestige standards
but they didn't deserve to get a zero
rating on Rotten Tomatoes or a 26 on
Rotten Tomatoes and stuff like that and
a lot of the WB uh movies didn't deserve
certain low scores on Rotten Tomatoes
and people started finding out when they
did watch these movies that these movies
actually were better than expected and
if they continue to use Rotten Tomatoes
as a metric to their viewing pleasure
they were going to be at a disadvantage
it's happening now Metacritic is doing
it to self so usually what happens is in
order to start something new something
must Rise Up from this right so maybe
somebody's watching right now and maybe
some genius has formed some analytics
that they're able to bring a fruition
and they're trying to push their
analytics and what I say is go to people
that you trust and and listen to their
reviews because a lot of times you won't
try something based on the consensus of
the group you have to be very strong
mind and strong willed in order to go
against the tide and say I don't care
what anybody says I'm playing that game
because I want to play the game and I'm
gonna make and formulate my own opinion
now in a society where everybody is
talking about views and clicks and
wanting to be having the most followers
and and most people around them it's a
little bit harder in the social media
area we have to come to a different
consensus things has to change but but
it has to be completely broken in order
for that change to come yeah I'm there
with you on it you know we've seen over
and over again I I don't care what
people say you know it's not a
coincidence that Starfield rated better
early on than than than later on and I
get it people are saying well it's the
people that sent them codes not everyone
gave Starfield bad reviews after they
got codes that didn't get codes it just
seemed like entitled media that didn't
and that's just my personal opinion on
the matter I don't know if that's true I
don't know these people's agendas but
all I know is like Euro gamer on all
them and there was a few Gamers that a
few websites that literally said I'm
giving this a six no matter what and
yeah
yeah and to me it's like you know if
that's the case that people gave this to
six just as like a political statement
like a gaming political statement shame
on them and you know the fact that
Metacritic just allows that to just
simmer on like people were upset that
that individual gay uh Spider-Man man of
seven and it's like but you could flip
that around like people were saying post
before the game came out the day one
patch broke a lot of things and then
these are individuals playing the game
after the Patch yeah and and you would
it would make more sense
that
hello
I think addict's internet went
out adct is frozen can y'all guys hear
me he said they got him can y'all hear
me
still put ones in the chat if y'all can
hear
me
all right so everybody's putting yes
that they can hear me ones ones ones all
right so this is the part where I froze
adct and I take over adct oh adct is
gone but I'm still here all right
guys what is that Super
Chat man down man down all right yo let
me switch my glasses because if I got to
read super chats s his on
babyy hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey welcome to the first official Xbox
Frontline
show Lord
King listen I want y'all to know
tomorrow like so after this video right
here after this right now Xbox Frontline
is going to debut we got a uh I I I did
a video video's gonna go up it's gonna
be crazy but at the same time on Friday
when the show go live and it's a working
progress people because I'm still
waiting on some for some stuff to happen
I got graphic guard uh finishing the
overlays and all that other stuff and
then you know I got sha Le on the intro
I got Dallas the man doing the the the
the you know his vocals but um R to
drumstar you know he passed away so he's
not going to do the Beats this time uh
we we're going to be going with Dallas
checking out Dallas we're going to talk
about that but
um at the same time I got a free game
giveaway all right so we gon we G we
gonna tear it up it's gonna be a free
game
giveaway live on air you know how I do
and don't forget we at two we made two
2K we did 2K we at 2K now y we did 2K
fast as hell um I'm super excited that
we did 2 okay uh uh you guys did that
you guys pushed it um you guys you guys
did that uh so don't forget we got a
statue giveaway I gotta sit down with
Sovereign because he has to uh give me
like is a bot that takes all the members
and then it rolls them around and then
it spits it out and then I got the
winner so it's gonna be you know statue
is gonna go out to the winner I'm
shipping out the statue I'm fitting the
bill uh to get shipped out to the to the
individual but this is it my only caveat
is we're going to do a live Zoom
call um it's going to be on the show or
if I record it or whatever and then
we're going to put it out because I want
people to to know that you real that you
won you real you supported we got to
start showing our unity and that's how I
give back you understand uh you know
that's that's
that's addict's calling me hold
on what up adct had a power outage adct
had a power outage all right so you know
the black Harry Potter with the $2 Super
Chat it's the Frontline show now it's
lit I'm not gonna come back in I'm just
gonna direct to your thing the moment my
internet pops up so keep them distracted
for like two minutes okay you heard that
I'mma keep you distracted for like two
minutes is the title fine yeah the
title's the title's perfect bro
okay all right peace do your
thing all right so anyway like I was
saying I'mma ship the statue out we're
gonna record it we're gonna put it up
and it's it's the show to give back
right and then when um you able to
subscribe to the channels soon as I get
uh 100 um subscribers I'm giving away
another statue I don't know which one
I'm looking at them I'mma figure out
which one is gonna give away hold on we
got man dingo MC Dickens $5 Super Chat
Jim Ryan said the zesty goons after
addict you never know when you're going
to need some Vaseline
hey definitely not definitely not but um
all right so check it out uh it it
that's gonna go out and then on patreon
when we get 100 patreon members another
statue is gonna go out so that's three
statues in that period of time and what
I'm trying to do is remember it's going
to be uh live calling show I don't know
if we're going to do it with Discord and
pull people from the Discord there he
goes adct is back that's my guy ad is
back someone say adct on his stomach you
guys gotta stop with that
hey all right so I mean we pretty much
like you know uh the whole point of that
topic was because d uh I thought we
would get through them quicker um did we
get all the super chats um I believe I
got all the super chats let me go back
up I was I wasn't keeping track of the
super chat if your Super Chat wasn't um
Let me let me just get them just to be
on the safe side5 Super Chat from Bay
Area shout out to adct and my dark uh
homy dirt but especially to the man who
has and will continue to hold the line
down King glad to see you shine brother
blessings uh then we got a $2 super trat
from gone mad has King ever done a full
tour of the statues no I've never done a
full tour cuz I had three rooms and then
I had to condense and all type of wild
and then um we got a $2 trap from the
angry therapist MD man down man down is
that I guess that's what I
left then we got a $2 Super Chat from
txx 10138 finishing
fality yo when you got stuck I was like
what I forgot that I'm on streamyard see
if we was on OBS this would be a wrap
like I would have done this uh $2 super
CH from the black Harry Potter it's the
Frontline show now it's lit oh my God I
don't even want to know what you were
saying $5 Super Chat from M mango big
thickens Jim Ryan sent in the zy goons
after addict you never know when you're
going to need some Vaseline oh my God $2
chat from uh dopus the ghost where did
you buy your statues from King okay so
XM Studios I buy them U I have a connect
overseas that I buy them and a lot of
times I buy from spec fiction so if
anybody knows uh specfiction go to spec
fiction.net uh you and if you know Todd
Johnson on Facebook that's my guy if you
need any links to it let me know I'll
send it to you and if you're just
starting off I would tell you to go to
Sideshow get a couple of statues from
Sideshow they don't they're relatively
uh cheap you say you can get them
anywhere from $150 all the way up to a
thousand and some change depending on
your space and depending on your
desires you heard them folks so uh I
have it already premiering I'm going to
go ahead and S you guys over there uh
you know you'll have your little uh cuz
what what's funny is like when you
Premiere it's got like a three minute
wait period or something appreciate King
for holding it down I don't know what
happened there man I it's just like I I
had a flash for a couple seconds it
wasn't the whole house it was just it
was just this though it was kind of
weird uh so let me go ahead uh right
there I see it right there so I'm gonna
send you guys over there uh definitely
you know um hit that like button man on
your way out hit the like button over
there please we we got 400 and some
change hit that like button please you
know um we gave you great entertainment
and adct adct definitely jump back in
some people would have just you know yo
King dead the stream N I wanted to make
sure that uh it was a good here to there
kind of thing but I'll talk to you guys
later we're gonna send you guys over
there
peace